hey what's up video games I was
complaining last month but all the stuff
getting leaked into 2016 bushed we
questioned laid yeah 2015's a bunch of
great games coming out still we're gonna
talk about those later but first of all
a bunch great games came out last month
march was pretty killer yeah kinda Adam
I don't say out of nowhere probably
shouldn't seeing one or two in common
but it was relief shall we say
especially something a whole bunch of
great things especially I think would
blood-borne cuz I was real worried that
last year there was some big hyper and
some Triple A games that fell you know
way flash of what what people were
looking for a way short of the mark at
blood-borne 9 out of 10 on gamespot one
of three last month he having are you
review blood-borne yeah I totally reub
still talking about born I haven't
played blood work has I've been so busy
no really yeah I what haven't you beaten
blood-borne I did yeah I did beat blower
game right you did I'm uh I'm in you
know I and then I got two bosses into
New Game+ mmm and I need to get back um
but I've been I've been kind of busy
yeah cuz games keep coming out well we
talked about all this new ones later
I've been playing blood-borne since I
got back from Poland I was away the week
that it came out and I never really
played much of dark so stuff that they
talk shows to a little bit but not so
much hmm I am absolutely in love with
this game it's it's it's actually
weirdly snackable which I wasn't sort of
anticipating I thought this was a sit
down for four hours and players yep but
I'm finding I'm able to play this game
for like yeah like 30 minutes or an hour
and just run out get a bunch of souls
and then orb sorry yeah blood blood of
omens blood blow Jose no Jose punch blow
chose low chose and blood dues cold cold
blood mountain dews yeah my coop this is
this is a new game plus father guest
coins yeah me and my co op buddy we're
going at it naughty I totally agree i
use a box like just being able to like
yet maybe you pull back you know you
bring back some blow chose and you level
up maybe you unlock a shortcut or two
which they seem yet prevalent in this
one I just feel like the progression is
I don't know maybe it's the experience
I've had with other Souls games which
has basically been like feel super super
into them and passionate about them but
not actually get past that there
or forcible for rice just because you
know because I don't think you could
have that experience like if I played
dark souls 2 for 45 minutes I could end
up worse off than i was when i started
with blood-borne that's not gonna happen
and yeah needless to say from our
discussion earlier about blood-borne
dreams it's lodged in there yeah III
it's not as difficult as what people
were telling me either or it's difficult
in like the way like a game like rogue
legacy is difficult to really it doesn't
matter you keep banking all your stuff
like you're never it's every that much
risk to go out into the world and do
stuff like worst case now you collect
like nine thousand souls you end up
dying or blood blowjo is very [ __ ]
and like but most of the time you can
just go back and like sing cadenza
leveling open there's not much of a you
know bad things if they happen then it's
just like 30 minutes burned but it's not
so bad another game i'm trying to find
time for at the moment isn't that again
the Kevin reviewed or e in the plan for
I do all of the things they think
they're you love you yeah um or in the
blank for us you know what that was the
big surprise for me hmm um it like we
got the review coat on fri dance like yo
dude you can put this up on monday yeah
or whatever it's like a [ __ ] so it's
basically there was my weekend i was
like oh I have to play the week i'm
playing a video game oh how awful um but
seriously like this thing like i always
saw it as pretty yes but I I didn't know
it was gonna be that good and even even
the opening just I mean it's the first
ten minutes of this game are just
emotionally gut wrecking I mean just I
was I was wrecked I'm 10 minutes I've
the platforming I absolutely adore
because it keeps me like every little
area is totally like makes you use all
the tools that you have that you've
learned up to that point in like new and
interesting ways and you keep unlocking
new ways I mean that's what you're
unlocking really earn new ways to move
the world and everything that you do to
move in this game just feel so wonderful
like that like that whole thing where
you latch on to stuff and fling yourself
and you fling the projectile into the
other direction like that is such a
fantastic way to move through a world
and Chris the escape things oh my god oh
the escape levels yes talk about those
all right
to your ass point about the movement
being you know there's a Metroidvania
like you're getting more and more
abilities and you're stacking them and
bringing them together but because
they're all movement focused they all
culminate so beautifully in these escape
levels where there's water rising and
you have to stay ahead of it or there's
a lot of following you or whatever or
there's this it's this air situation and
you're good you they're not easy like
they definitely take a bunch of tries to
get through and sometimes like you're
like I you almost had it but they like
hit this such a sweet spot of just like
capitalizing on all the skills and just
like being so thrilling a way to to like
really feel your own power and the way
you've been growing and the way you the
game play experience has been evolving
it's not just that like you encounter
enemies that were tough before but now
you laugh at them is like your whole
experience of moving through the world
evolves as the game goes along and
that's I mean that I like hundred
percent of the my playthrough not all
the achievements cuz there's like some
speedrun stuff in there which is deadly
but I loved it and it was it was the
movement that did it for me yeah game
that I reviewed I don't review many
games for gamespot a hotline Miami 2 I
cannot talk about enough about how much
I adored this game and the idol was a
big fan of the first game I reviewed the
first game as well the second one for me
and I know this has been divisive both
online and and Iran like talking to the
guys a giant bomb we're talking to folks
here as well and I love the fact that
that game pigeon-holed you into saying
like hey guess what you have to be good
at shooting you can't just tony the
tiger your way through this entire game
and what i loved about it was I think
it's so much harder than the first one
as well and I've completed it on this
I'm playing it through at the moment on
PlayStation 4 the hard mode in this game
is just like the most fun it's
terrifyingly unforgiving the games about
three or four times longer the first
game as well and I just love how like
like you're like this some of the some
of the characters they only allow you to
use gone someday only ladies use melee
like this dude here or this police
station man with like so brutal with a
little mini boss how
how did you enjoy it oh I mean I had
like I really this this level in
particular like if I get got me into
this that loop of like like as you can
yeah but you're like I gotta hit the guy
with gun first and then the two other
guys are going to come out I can pop
them but then the guy is going to be
coming around the corner and if they're
alerted and then you know you like you
just start stacking it up and because it
does that thing where it repeats you
know you respawn immediately you can
just keep grinding at it and you get
into this intense this zone of the like
and at its best you're like in this
crazy flow and like obviously I was
pulling these like John Woo like that
spin shots like pulling around backwards
and mop and dudes heads off like and
then you know totally getting killed for
my hubris but just I it yeah it that it
nails that loop for me and I'd i agree
with you Danny I really liked that it
forced me to play levels in different
ways based on the parameters yeah a
fantastic static as well of course I'm
still waiting for my vinyl to arrive
dumped 70 bucks and not nonsense you
even that what do you listen to a vinyl
they have a vinyl player Julia a vinyl
hey we're gonna like do vinyls tonight
honey I'm gonna make it easy tip serpent
roll on one of them vinyl situations we
got I said there was three games that
got nine out of ten I'm actually wrong
there was another one at mark Walton
reviewed devil may cry Oh double may cry
like enhanced edition to definitive
winner is it definitive forget exactly
what the it's DMC next-gen yeah ultimate
next-gen Korea version of the total you
know talk about all these and
re-releases we keep seeing on these
consoles this was a fantastic game at
the end of the lacs last i console
lifecycle did what speaking for now
review what did they add much to this
new version no i don't i don't think
they added auto mode um but i but i
think that they added some stuff to make
it harder they did the same thing for
devil may cry for mm actually as well
they added some stuff that made that
game harder of course ee my cry for was
harder than DMC hmm um but you know why
i didn't finish DMC because you know
again that a whole time thing yeah but i
really liked what i played and I felt
like is somebody who's always loved
devil may cry i reviewed for
I was just felt like it was a you know
DMC ghatal gets a lot of flack from the
fan base tonight I sort of get it but I
feel like some of that's a little
manufactured like on its own terms this
game is just so good yeah people don't
like China's feels really good and I
mean yeah I'll back it up it's it's the
Invisible War of the devil may cry
franchise didn't get the didn't compete
you know the love it deserved when it
first came out but in time give us some
time shame to still waiting for Ninja
Theory to have that one big commercial
hit I had one thing that did change in I
one has actually changed the ending and
so the other the damn thing in the
previous version had so this ambiguous
you know part two might be coming soon
and this one doesn't this one's straight
up egg walking into the background this
may be it this yet idea that's it we're
done yeah but at nine out of ten we're
talking all about these night of the 10
games some great edited 10 games came in
at last just across the board city
skylines fantastic game I'd be like
jumping errors into that and I feel like
that game I will click on any link that
anyone posts about that game because
it's inevitably just this awesome parade
of screenshots and some bizarre weird
story about what they did about how they
made a poop lake and put people on poop
island or all about it they made an
entire city with just one family living
in it both ways you see pc gamer did
this great article on just building a
city with enough to have like to put one
a single family really and like track
him around for a while there wasn't even
anyone there and the game was like try
to spot your one inhabitant in your
entire city you've made just for them so
it's just fascinating in our australia
office has been huge into it and just
like put sharing their own stories over
and over again mod scene is yeah it's
just huge for this game it really is
everything people wanted a news from a
new sim city yes is it just everything
people wanted or is it like more is it
its own unique kind of like beyond
SimCity things immersed in shitty like I
think it feels super SimCity and what
what makes it feel like that for me is
the fact that like there are so many of
these complex systems but they all just
seem to like make a lot of sense like
there's so much
complex nonsense happening in this game
but it all feels totally digestible and
it's like it's given to you and like
unlock to you in a from in a way that
feels completely natural as your city
expands and I get it it's amazing it's
like it reminds me of like SimCity 2000
like it may be the best like City
creation game apparently they deliver on
the whole idea of Sims having their own
lives because like that's one of the
things that was supposed to make the new
sim yes so good and then they basically
cheated us out of that this actually
pulls off what it's supposed to do with
a queen you and then if you want you can
find them and destroy their [ __ ]
house what they say if they talk trash
about your city you can click on it fine
eyes when they go home at night and then
just Boulder hotel us he'd be like BAM
what do you think about water charges
now better think twice before you tweet
at hate Daniel Dwyer ass mayor Donna
your dryer speaking of Mayors we had a
mayor review that Brett Todd totally
Brett taught as a mayor look mayor has
actually been freelancing for us for a
lot longer than I worked at Cape spot
far before he was a mare oh yeah but
he's totally a mayor in a Canadian town
he's the mayor of Canada yes actually
there you go a bunch more games olly
olly to go native town in fact this week
we'd pillars of eternity yeah great game
I have a great review from there and MLB
15 which Mary just put the video review
also relieved by a mayor yeah really the
same mayor red Todd I don't have
multiple threats are what's going on
your tan man God's time to be reviewing
video games for gamespot com he's a
magic mayor ya know ah yes it turns out
some pretty great games I like how about
that we're so lucky I wonder if there's
any maybe there's some coming out this
week Mortal Kombat grand theft auto 5 PC
never maybe she hates and lines in there
as well maybe maybe or maybe a few ones
and dues you know good or I just never
know mike 2 k.com next week to find out
oh damn says their tape and we're gonna
be back in just a minute talking about
the games that are left in 2015
you